avec l'été finissant revoici le temps
des défilés de mode nous avons longtemps
évoqué ici les tendances de la mode pour
ce qui se rapporte aux dames et cela
pour la plus grande joie des messieurs
surtout lorsqu'il s'agissait des
maillots de bain ce sont aujourd'hui les
hommes qui sont à l'honneur avec deux
salons qui les concernent directement et
un changement de tendance l'irruption du
sport dans la mode comme France Roche a
pu le
noter invité tout sourire et tout muscle
au Paris Country Club avec Jean Terlin r
Brunet
Pascal ul François et les deux médaillés
olympiques Frédéric Delcour et Catherine
poire non non on n'était pas là pour
ronter ses exploits on venait assister à
la première collection sport de l'anin
qui était jusqu'alors plutôt spécialisée
dans les costumes très chers pour
messieurs très sérieux Alexandre
patovski a décidé de faire passer sur la
maison un souffle de grand terre la
preuve les tenues de mariés ont été
présenté par Sylvie et Frédéric nos
médaillers les médailles ne sont
naturellement pas vendu che
lenvin passons au vrai mannequin tout en
éponge velourd il y a le genre immaculé
dans le style demain j'enlève le
bas on peut jouer aussi sur les couleurs
soives cerise vert de mer avec une
pointe de
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Parme plus sévère la tenue mi karaté mi
yogi ce serait dommage de déchirer ce
brocard par des mouvements trop violents
petit Jésus moderne vagabondant sur les
[Musique]
golfs jeune loup de plage pêcheur de
Minett et affrontant les tempête autour
de daville les casquettes servent à
faire le trajet pour descendre déjeuner
à la
plage costume d'mire méditant une
augmentation du pétrole afin d'habiller
de neuf sa garde royale
ça ça se vendra beaucoup entre le ket et
le
Qatar un peu fakir un peu Laurence
d'Arabi avec un rien de mystique est-ce
une tenue de sport ou de
méditation celle-là en tout cas c'est
bien pour imiter l'aventurier de l'arche
perdu Indiana Jones en plus
propre un tour vers la nouvelleorléand
visite de la plantation en Panama
blanc un homme cassis un homme caramel
mais parsin de glace préféré
j'achète Madra écossais pour activités
diverses et pour un sport nommé bourse
costume avec lunettes pour mieux voir
les zéros et gants pour mieux compter
les billets enfin pour un sport que je
n'ose pas ou à peine deviner un ensemble
pas négligé pour dessous mais que diable
cache-t-il pour ça dans leur inch
caisse